this concept of being an influencer
right you guys are influencers so you
know what's nuts is
um you guys have kids so you're probably
familiar with this is that every kid
wants to be an influencer these days
wild stat Bloomberg just did a report
apparently 98 of kids right in between
uh six and twelve when they grow up they
want to be influencers 98 okay so when I
was growing up it was doctors lawyers
astronauts athletes whatever it is
president now basically 98 of kids are
basically saying give me Tick Tock or
give me death like I'm out of this thing
so you guys are in real life actual
influencers you have kids that I assume
have social media profiles at this point
so my question is do you want your kids
to be influencers when they grow up yeah
absolutely I want them not to be the
so-called influencer I want them to have
a social media I want them to put
themselves out there and build their
personal brand and if it leads to them
influencing some the somebody to buy a
service or product so be it I just want
them to actually have a social media be
active on social media in case you never
know what what can happen because you
know followers maybe maybe Jaden wants
to promote something and showcase what
he's doing maybe in Jiu Jitsu or he
started this cool candy business maybe
that business could lead to another
business that'll eventually be able to
promote to his followers so it's not I
wanted to be an influencer I just wanted
to be active on social media gotcha so
y'all does the same thing with uh her
tick tocks I want the kids to do
whatever they want to do believe it or
not because we've always been recording
them since they were babies yeah and
we're all about you know recording and
creating content and they're used to
that and they know that it's worked for
Mommy and Daddy
but my son doesn't want to be an
influencer yeah try to get them to me
Tick Tock and his Tick Tock is not he
used to when he was little show face but
now it's all edits that he does he loves
editing videos he loves got it the same
thing with my daughter Brielle she um
she loved she loves the attention but at
the same time now she's posting more
edits they're already more like for
example Jaden wants to be an actor
Brian wants to be a singer so they're
not like I want to be an influencer
because they see our work and to them is
not something that they look forward to
a little young too but they're 11 and
eight no I think they're they're they
know what they want I think they see us
doing it so it's not something that they
I feel like people that are not around
influencers they look up to it but they
don't really see the work behind the
scenes exactly how many times I tell
them like wait that was funny go back
and do it again for me to record it or
like no wait Jayden do it again you did
I've been doing that to them since they
were little and they know it's work and
then they're good actors what they just
did it's not something that like oh I
already do that at home I don't want to
do that after school or you know like
actually Jayden gets embarrassed when
his friends Google US yeah and his
friends go like oh my God we googled
your parents and Jayden's like no no you
know like it's Thursday they're just
normal people like like yeah Peru they
just grow up in humble beginnings no big
deal the way you just edified him and
you showed his Instagram to me I'm
looking and I'm like oh my God that's
just my husband you know like yeah which
is amazing but it's just it's just us so
go deeper on like the benefits of the
kids having social media at such a young
age what do you see as the benefits I
mean besides the fact that they get free
clothes and they've gotten you know all
the pr packaging since they were little
for content and stuff
um the benefits
they're very very confident but I think
that's also the way they were raised you
know I'm really big with affirmations
and we took parenting classes and we're
present parents which that's amazing
um but at the same time to them it's
really uncomfortable when we go on a
trip and people want like hey Jay hey
Christy pictures they do get a little
shy and they do on their privacy you
know have you seen like the anything out
there there's going to be good and bad
okay it's whether you watch television
play video games play sports there's
always going to be good things and bad
things so I'm Never Gonna Knock social
media the reason that I even know you
guys is because of social media but I
feel like at such a young age I'm not
even talking about your kids there has
to be some consequences and some issues
that come up with kids having social
media and your guys experience what's
sort of the downside of kids whether
it's you know aged 8 10 12 15 being on
social media like literally on social
media or even watching social media what
do you think the downside is
they see everything that we do we can't
play hooky from school until the kids
are sick and go on vacation or uh I
don't know I can't talk about Jamie's
candy business because all the teachers
follow us
they might shut them down I think I
think that's just superficial
um
but privacy maybe you know they don't
want to be put out there yeah
because I mean think about it when we
were growing up we're a similar age dude
we we barely had beepers yeah yeah okay
yeah like that was like if you want to
get in touch with me beat me right then
it turned into a cell phone right well
like a Blackberry or even before that a
raise or whatever the hell it was then
became an iPhone and then with an iPhone
you can start
FaceTiming people and then all of a
sudden privacy okay and then Facebook
started showing up all right I'm gonna
elect to put my stuff out there and then
it's like all right even before Facebook
you had Friendster in Myspace all right
it was a conscious like I have to
register this then it's like all right
social media it's so called Instagram
Snapchat
uh Tick Tock to YouTube out there and
then less and less and less privacy in
your life so now you're talking about
your kids they've had a social media
profile since the day where they were
born even pbd his kids boom they they
assign them social media profiles at
Birth I'm just wondering I don't have
kids as a parent there must be some like
talks you need to have to say this isn't
real life there's filters out there
don't believe that that was probably
edited you probably have to like teach
them other things that we didn't have to
learn as a kid
I was just gonna say that I think is the
the dopamine that they get on the daily
because even my daughter you know she's
six and she'll be like Mommy I got five
new followers today so to them that at
such a young age is like that's the
dopamine that's me being accepted that's
me being liked or my friend said this
about my content and so I'm always
trying to explain to them that that is
not real that all what matters is what
you think about yourself and how do you
feel how did you feel creating that Tick
Tock did you have fun yeah who cares if
you don't get you know the 20 likes that
you're expecting or whatever you know
it's like who how do you who did you
have fun did you enjoy it are you loving
it right and then so I'm really really
um I don't want to say strict because
they do love their gadgets but I'm very
careful that we do have that present
time yeah and you know we always remind
them that we're a team and we have
dinner together then we all and one
thing that I do love is that they share
absolutely everything with us like to
them we're we're their friends the same
way that I and today I told them I'm
like guys I'm going to a podcast you
know so I do it and I share my stuff
with them that I'm excited so they feel
comfortable doing it as well because
there's a lot of things that I mean not
in our case but a lot of kids do get
Cyber Bullied and do compare themselves
and when they don't have a friend or
someone to look up to or someone that's
in this type of world in the scene they
get depressed and they feel like they're
not worth anything and that's what they
want to be influencers when they grow up
but because you know the kids have seen
us and our work ethic and what it really
takes to have the freedom that we have
we do make sure that we enjoy that
present time with them and that is why
mommy and daddy work so hard so if you
like that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]